[Music]
white knight was set up to be kind of a
political thriller
curse was set up to be a historical
thriller and this will be a sci-fi
thriller at the end of the last volume i
have bruce going to jail some years have
gone by what happens is somebody breaks
into the ruins of wayne manor and steals
this super dangerous bat suit he decides
to escape he becomes a convict the
number one criminal on the run in gotham
hoping to finally put batman to bed and
there's kind of a civil war breaking out
in gotham you have these this
overreaching overpowered super cop
program run by dick then you have gcpd
the normal blue collar good cops the
idea was i really wanted to give beyond
fans everything they were looking for
but i also wanted to play with pieces in
a new unique way i really tried to
reinvent the terry mcginnis costume
but it just looks so good the way it was
if i complicate the suit it's just gonna
look wrong so i decided to just kind of
make him exactly how he was in the
original series the big reveal on the
last page if it doesn't make you want to
buy the rest of the series you are dead
inside
[Music]
you